歡迎收看最佛心幽默的財經節目
理財達人秀 我是李肇華
今天可以說是好消息不斷非常多力多的總和
而今天的成交量也順利的站上了趙元大關
有什麼樣的好消息呢
昨天晚上的CPI符合市場預期
9月的升息機率往下降了
市場不擔心了
資金又重新的
蔓延到市場上來了
而我們今天看到
MSCI
本來覺得三項全中
應該會有這樣的有生的
但是三項全生
今天外資是買超台股
700多億元
有一股資金回流的感覺
所以今天台股繼續往上漲
已經佔上了46000點
不過一體兩面
也有非常多的投資朋友說
啊
要說打第二隻腳
好像沒有呢
那如果直接V轉
內心又開始FORMOR了起來
市場的情緒我們不用這樣子
反反覆覆我們只要注意一件事情
資金有回流
我們整體的資金架構
正在往好的地方走
財報繳出來
半年報好的法說會講的
三律有三深的
今天盤面上就直接送您漲停板
財報會發威
看到明年有成長
這個是最重要的一件事情
選股其實邏輯就變得簡單多囉
來歡迎今天的三位來賓
第一位是谷科大夫
龍醫生Eason
好Eason說種種利多大概有四種
讓台股的資金結構
現在是往好的方向走
回到台灣來囉
韓股流出的雅股裡面
台股也有做接收喔
所以今天來告訴您
兩大產業
之前Eason就在看被動元件
可是處置期先
無量下跌怎麼講也沒有用
現在反彈了
今天Eason挑出一批
反彈位階十分合理
他的營收狀況也很好的
可以直接做介入的被動元件
以及CPU
我們常常講這波反攻的先鋒
就是CPU
今天排名上有一點點小壓迴
在等柯西倫的財報的狀態
但是壓迴的
發現挪威主權基金在買
等一下來幫您挑
好 第二位
是我們的黃金右下角
懸鼓教練韋泰
維泰也要來救援了
紅海昨天的法說明明講得很好
毛利率少了一點點
今天就壓回
但華碩卻是狹帶著強烈的半年爆成機
掌聽板 廣達呢
明天廣達的命運
等一下維泰來揭曉
但無論如何這些AI以線均
對應明年
現在EPS 直利率等等
都便宜到不行
還有就是看到像PCB跟封測了
PCB本來MSI有納入的喔
現在錦碩這些台要
因為被處置延後生效
導致旁邊上有壓抑
有壓抑
但財報好的
等一下幫您挑真正的黃金右下角
第三位是我們的存股交付股育
股育要來告訴大家
大家知道現在台股市值破
兆元的公司高達21檔
兆元的時代來了
但這裡面有好公司
有大公司也有非常高價的公司
到底哪一些符合他覺得
價值宣估的標的呢
那如果想要一網打包的話
其實除了ETF 不要忘記喔
基金3000塊錢就可以扣款的
而且現在基金有很多的機制
邦尼怎麼樣
下跌的時候你自己不要操作啦
他幫你自動扣嘛
之前說扣不到
其實七月可以扣到10次
有扣到的朋友都分享超讚
等一下教你喔
下次遇到這樣的情況
自動扣邦尼在這一次的反彈
賺好賺滿喔
好首先有請Eason
好Eason終於現在看起來
大家都開始親來我們台股了
可是這樣一談就6000點
又開始有人覺得好formal
不要formal
因為現在利多其具
資金是回流的
這是一個好現象
那被動你今天很殺喔
你說有一些已經可以叫直接買
然後有一些是CPO拉回
可以做布局
那我們先再看一下國際的部分
那個CPI又這個就是年增率
跟月增公佈出來之後
符合預期
所以導致呢
在升息的機率又來到四成了
說實在因為馬上接近美國其中選舉
那如果貿然這個時間點升息
可能有一些多餘的政治動作解讀
就覺得可能還是岸兵不動
的機率是比較大的
那在接下來這個
MSCI調整台股的權重
因為7月暴跌
大家本來還有人預期說
會不會台股權重被調降
結果給大家一個驚喜
跟大家解釋一下什麼叫驚喜
就是全球的市場的權重
新一市場開始調升
除了日本以外也在做一個調升
包括台股
有很多股票去做一個納入
等於三種我們都是生
對
所以看到最近其實外資
買台股買得非常的用力
包括台幣也在做一個升值
挪威主權基金也是
台積電買最多
到6月底為止
也買了一坨拉股的台股
包括台間聯發科台大店紅海國巨也有
還有日銳光台光店
志邦星星跟聯電
所以看起來在AI的浪潮當中
很多外資看起來還是滿清爛台股的
其實台股目前我覺得最弱都開始反彈了
最弱的開始反彈了 誰呢 環球金
環球金細金圓已經連續兩根漲停了
然後在台大店也開始頂部反彈了
大家如果看這些股票
可能他的籌碼都還很爛
像國劇啊 像談談電影
從嘛確實都還蠻爛
強貌也不太好 這普普的
主動元件的強貌
對 信心緣好不到那裡去
但是其實最弱的都反彈了
告訴大家一件事
台股要下來第二隻腳的機會
已經秒忙了
不會 對
秒忙
對 因為最弱都已經彈了嘛
最弱都已經開始有資音進場了
已經開始拉台了
所以不要說
台股會回可是回不生啦
如果以形態來講
這種一個平坦波修正
假設第一波反彈到這個地方
4萬到4萬4千點
第一波漲在4千點
那這邊再往上做一個慢慢的
這個走生的話呢
其實有機會來到這個對稱區域
對稱區域
4萬7千500點到4萬8千點
那包括外資呢
8月起也是很積極的在做一個轉買
最近這個
就是從8月初到現在為止
買超了1870幾億
我覺得這個反彈過程當中呢
只要沒有突然爆亮
比如來到1.3兆到1.4兆的話
基本上還不用太過於擔心
因為就是量能這樣緩緩的
再做一個增加
那今天大概是一兆快要一點一兆
那只要沒有突然的
有這個大筆的這個資金衝進去的話
我覺得這個反彈應該是可以延續的
那再來就是
包括農委主權基金還有MSEI的
雙題材
像最近還買了一些像
Polo Way 環語 和聲糖
所以他買了一些很多這種偏中型股
但是確實又有產業題材的股票
這個是大家可以去注意一下
挪威的這個主員基金
他買了一些股票
反而是比較有活潑的
比較有動能的
不過我們先來看被動元件
因為你有提到
我們要看被動元件是因為
有春田製作所
或三星電機這樣的廠商
終於都明確發動
今天在韓股大幅度反彈
包括昨天的記憶體
也大幅度的走升之下
今天韓股是記憶體
以及在被動都往上走高
所以大家不要覺得說國劇
魂鶯科這位為什麼七月疊這麼重
其實跟韓國
跟國際股市有很大的影響
可是今天春田製作
漲幅來到大概12%
然後三星電影漲幅大概15%
所以今天的被動最多就漲10%
在龍頭部分
漲幅還稍微落後一些些
那其實今天也是在
反韓第一段之後呢
第二段的這個被動
開始有這個表態的一個趨勢
所以我覺得應該這個漲勢
還沒有結束
那包括跟之前6月份
或七月份來比較
被動的產業面的一個消息
並沒有任何的改變
甚至可能還更好
那我之前有跟大家說
這樣子一個跌幅
已經可能跌了五成六成的話
就算它有什麼利空
就算它是產業面出現利空
也會有一個技術性反覽出現
更何況它現在的產業
是一直偏好消息一直出來了
包括之前 都收上去了
包括之前國劇
日電帽等等的法說都是這樣講
所以可以看得出來
在這個MLCC AI的這個部分持續帶動
不管是交期拉長
以及在急單的出貨
產能利用率都是蠻窄
以及在BB ratio都是
訂單是非常的旺的
所以我覺得這個族群很多
都是已經超殺的一個狀況
但是這個族群好煩喔
就是下去的時候那時候無量疊
一反彈每次動不動就變成都在漲停
大家就有點錯亂
想說這樣我還來得及脈嗎
對 那我覺得今天漲停
如果明天又開太高的話
可能稍微觀望一下
但是給大家一個原則就是
如果他在這一波的這個下跌
我們先舉這個例子先看一下
就這一波的下跌
這一波的下跌
核生糖
如果他反彈還不到0.382的話
那我覺得你事實上
這個切入的機會是還蠻多的
那只要這個短線不要大賞
或者是這個乖離不要太大撞下
其實還不到0.382
其實目標都會在這個位階
那當中像是國際就還沒有到
國際還沒到嗎
國際還沒到 因為跌太深了
都一堆腰閃 對
想說他都今天漲停啊
600多塊吧
華興課也還沒到
然後這個像麗龍店
麗龍店 金山店日天貌
都還沒到 因為都跌太深
如果大家最近看這個籌碼
通常是買不下手
因為籌碼真的還在
一個很爛的過程當中
我看到有一些投信在回補
但不是全面信的
對 某一些還在回補
開始回補 但是大部分都是
可能看籌碼還是在賣草
可是我覺得
要搭配股價 搭配起來看
因為籌碼一直是很差
一直有人在賣
可是既然賣不下去
反而股價還在往上漲
那可能被特定的人給收走了
那包括在這個合身堂
就是已經快要接近到
這個0.5的位階
那如果是這樣子一個狀況
快要到0.5的話
就即將要進入到7月
比較大的一個套路區
那這個地方可能就要稍微的
去調節一下部位
等待拉回再去做個進場
所以以一個大方向來看
可以這樣去做判斷
也不要盲目樂觀啦
因為畢竟還是有所謂的深水套老區
以核酸糖的問題剛剛講
他已經談得比較多了對不對
對 核酸糖就是100腰斬下來
那當然因為
1000腰斬下來
那因為後面這段其實在
處置是很大的一個因素影響
那處置這個緊咕咒把它拿掉之後呢
那事實上就看到
很多這種疊身骨瓢
不管被動 吸精源
這種已經這個疊很深的
刮破在功率元件也是
最近其實都是慢慢在往上做一個墊膏
那核身上來說的話
他的大戶持股相對是比較穩定的
投信這兩天也開始在做一個轉買
而且投信之前在高檔
這個套了一堆
套了比較高檔的位置
所以真正面臨到這個最後的關卡
大概就是在這個位階以上
以核身上來說
大概是在800塊以上
會面臨到比較大的一個壓力
不過他在AI相對的比重
占他營收是最多的
那另外其實在這個利機型的M-LCC的需求
也開始轉強
那他在高毛利的自製比重也逐步提升
所以第二季賺了3.87元
年增179%
他現在成為了被動的古王
也是一個指標之一
另外在這個也是打了三折的華興殼
不過他的營收表現
就確實也比較疲弱一點
對 那確實他的AI比重
可能相對比較低
但是跌升就最大的利多
就是跌再升再怎麼樣
都會進入這樣技術性的反彈
那最近其實如果大家看籌碼
可能會買不下去
一下子又有這個主力大賣
隔日充電
然後大壺在減少
然後外資也在賣
投信也在賣
那主力的這一天是隔日充電被盜獲了
就是漲停的隔日有被盜出來些些
那可是這一波反而第一檔
融資在這個地方去做大局的進場
我覺得這個應該算是很角色
因為這個很多的投資朋友
可能是買在半三有之前
買在半三或高檔
這個地方我覺得在大局進場
看起來不太像是他過去的一個操作手法
所以我覺得這個地方
反而融資可以當作是一個指標
也就是融資大買的這個低點有沒有被跌破
如果融資大買這個位置都沒有被跌破的話
反而我覺得應該還有機會再去往上做攻擊
那
市場上的神人很多
有人在這一波其實真的是被抬出去
但也有人在這邊希望能夠來減便宜的
所以看得出來聰明融資大戶是有著墨一些股票
因為其實低檔也有漲了三成四成這樣
這個也不少
所以大家我覺得現在你反而要注意
這個融資什麼時候跑掉
那個反而是一個重要的指標
那他隨著在AIPC AIS手機等等的這個發酵
那也有像D5衛星跟5G 6G
這些基礎建設的被動元件
那說實在他的這個AIS占比確實是比較低
不過最近華星集團
看起來都還蠻強勢的
包括連母公司華星
也搭上了一些鋼鐵的題材
所以我覺得大家可以去注意一下
這種真的已經超跌
跌到達到這個骨折之後
其實都會有迎來一個反彈
位階相對低
所以現在彈的話
也先不那麼再隱收
反而要看籌碼的變化對不對
那它比較大的一個套牢區
第一個壓力區大概會在這個地方
大概在這個接近400左右
那更大一個套牢區
大概在500之上
那其實你不要看
這個其實距離都還有
還有這個肉
我覺得其實今天漲停板
那只要未來這兩天
三天還有機會的話
大家可以去注意一下
另外則在CPO部分非常多好消息
包括美股這一波的反彈
主要在CPO
包括Luminten的財報
以及Coherent的財報
不過畢竟第一檔
這個都反彈起來七成八成了
所以呢
短線有一些震盪也算合理
那包括在資本支出部分
也都在做一個增加
以及毛利率提升
然後輝達也開始要再入股這個
中繼蓄創
全球最大的光模組的廠商
剛剛有問你說
他為什麼可以就是買中國廠商啊
他想買就拍
因為想說美中之間的
台灣是不能隨便入股大陸
那個美國應該沒有這樣規定
對
那挪威主權基金在2005年8月的時候呢
也曾經大買過CPU
當時光盛還在四五百塊左右
這一次是挪威主權基金
還蠻廣受大家討論的一次
因為大家說怎麼會買了五檔哦
都是小型股
是不是本土主力在幫忙操盤
但後來事後來看這些都變大標股
我覺得不可能啦
因為要了解台灣的中小型股
還是要台灣的投資者插版手比較容易知道
畢竟這些資訊可能還是台灣才比較能夠接受得到
不是那麼透明
所以在光通訊族群當中這一波先漲了
但因為現在大概一兆左右的這個成要量能
所以呢今天被動起來
然後細菁園這兩天起來
光通訊今天就有一些漲太動
所以如果持續維持在一兆左右這個量能的話
各股的輪動速度可能會稍微快些些
大家要抓一下這個節奏
不要連續漲了4跟5分鐘
才進去做個追價
那我們看到其實指標
像是這個連亞 光盛這個都長得非常多的話
可能建議等拉回季線再買
或拉回月線再買
那有一些呢
位階相對比較低的
我覺得可以先買一半左右的這個部位
先去做卡位
所以即使在同個族群當中
位階不一樣
我覺得操作策略也要稍微有一些彈性
那在這個245全新的部分
大戶持股算是比較穩定的
短線在這地方有稍微爆亮
所以這地方上次有跟大家說
不要去做一個追價
那現在正當整理之後
其實這兩三件如果跟隨
每股或者是CPU有拉回的話
可以再去注意一下
三月的第三季營收計幟23%
那今天EPS估計
三塊五到四塊多
雖然說現在看起來
這個可能本來比稍微高一些些
但是大家看的是
未來切入在零花鷹這一塊的題材
那零花鷹其實未來在
觀衆訊當中也是非常缺了
然後呢這個市場都給予比較高的評價
像美股的ASTIS
就是這波反彈超過100%
所以我覺得相關零化鷹的這個連亞全新
大家可以去注意
好這個是在零化鷹題材的部分
那另外的話有發現
這次加碼的CPU有Poro微緩雨
看起來也都是後面有一些故事的
像Poro微緩雨就是長期跟輝達去做一個合作
那看到最近的這個
上檔第一波之後呢
也開始亮縮下來
籌碼開始穩定
所以CPU如果目前要直接買的
就是像這樣子
上漲一波之後
他並沒有說
已經漲到季線資產或管理非常大的
像最近在這種橫盤震盪的
我覺得可以去先佈局一半的部位
那基本上要再打下來機會
也不是那麼高了
所以如果未來有進一步突破的時候
再去做一個加碼
可以這個策略去做操作
總之我覺得現在大家
對於台灣發展AI的方向
感覺上認同度還是非常高
市場恐慌情緒貧富後
可以重新來評估了
這邊非常謝謝Eason
好 Eason要提醒
現在盤面上面
看到大家對於升息的疑慮
降低了
外資也回來買了
因為台幣也恢復到
比較升值的方向
所以資金如果回流一注
這個是很大的事
因為整個上半年
我們被外資賣的是個亂七八糟
如果能夠回流
我們又重新評估
所謂的基本面跟籌碼面的話
有非常多的公司
現在在好的軌道上
被動元件
其實七月營收已經陸續開出來
都不錯的情況
而法人雖然現在還沒有侵賴
可是有例如聰明融資
或形態上怎麼樣也賣不下去的
這邊反彈到0.382附近的
都還蠻值得做介入以及CPO
因為國際大廠的好消息真的很多喔
這一波的形態也是強勢表態
加上挪威主權基金的加持
這邊也是提供給您做參考
廣告回來 微太要上場啦
好 今天華碩掌評版
因為昨天他們的法說跟半年報
真的就是一個VERBAN
廣達下午的成績也是很好
明天能不能還這些老AI的工道呢
至於這個所謂的MSI
這是暫緩納入所謂的
難電警鎖等等的
發生什麼事了
其實有好財報的話
都不要擔心喔
我是古事分析師
同時也是兩個孩子的爸爸
很多人常問我
到底該幫小孩存台積電
還是0050
其實我的答案很簡單
其實只要定期定額
以年化報酬率8%估算
負力累積下來
孩子成年18歲都會有第一桶金
而問我
最看重的是哪一檔股票
在我心中
當然就是我的孩子
孩子的黃金發育期只有一次
所以更應該幫孩子存未來
在孩子轉大人的關鍵期
我的秘密武器就是這個
裝廣合堂
轉大人脆低金
由台灣第一位女中醫師
莊淑琦博士開立
有征外孫三胞胎成長時政
男女配方不同的
成龍成鳳配方
剛好可以精準補給黃金琴營養
是不是都沒有苦味和腥味
對阿娟跟媽媽整個姿態應該好喝的
嗯 好好喝喔
投資我會挑龍頭骨
陪孩子成長
我挑有時政的龍頭品牌
這才是最精準的健康投資
好 最近在上漲
可以說不用太擔心的關係是有一塊
叫做我們的AI移線軍
他帶動指數往上走
而他們的本益比
如果對應其明年的成長性
超低 直立率都很棒
這個是一個
那另外我們發現現在資金又重新回到
青睞 PCB 上到下都有喔
但是現在卻傳出 MSI 要納入的
載板類喔
因為分盤交易的關係
可能要暫緩
到底怎麼回事
這邊來請教委嘆
每次都要來解讀這些
法說我們要變法會
然後為什麼會納入暫緩
還有今天還要加碼一個
風策股
你覺得它就是一個
現在完全價值還沒有被彰顯的產業
好 我們現在看一下今天
剛剛出爐的這個廣達
他在這個第二季的一個財報數字
我們先來跟大家來解讀一下
第二季營收是1.04兆
哇 兆華的兆
謝謝
計幀28.1% 年幀105.6%
哇 讚
毛利玉大家會很關心
為什麼 因為他只有5.02%
比鴻海低
對 但是比毛三倒數要好
我們從哪個角度看
計增0.24% 年減2.03%
然後再來稅後存易的部分
計增35.2% 然後年增69.9%
好 那麼這樣子的一個數字
我們可以看到就是
他在今年第二季的EPS7.43元
OK 叫今年第一季是成長
因為今年第一季是5.5元
但是也叫去年第二季成長
因為去年第二季成長4.37元
我相信可能會有一些投資朋友
會認為說毛利率5.02
這個叫去年還年減2.03%
以為這個是比較不好的消息
但是我們可以觀察到
就是它的營收
因為營收年資率是一倍
超過100%的一個成長
所以使得他在整個營收
這個大幅度成長的情況之下
獲利也是大幅度的成長
所以我基本上認為
今天的廣達的數字來看
明天的股價應該是有機會
是往上去做走高的
是
好 那麼往上再做走高的過程當中
可能還有幾個關卡要去看
哪些關卡
第一個就是
這波其實從這個地方往上反彈的
一個過程當中說實話
其實反彈的強度並不是特別的強
所以往上反彈
可能第一個要先看到的這個地方
他在之前的後面這一段的一個
這個孔方性賣壓所造成的一個
解套性賣壓
能不能夠去做一個客服
再來這邊還有一個
所謂的一個初權席的這個
所謂的空防缺孔
這兩個關卡應該都是接下來
當這個股價要往上去做反彈的時候
必須要去特別做關注的一個價量點
好 昨天華碩當然自然他的財報
非常亮麗是個歷史新高的狀態
然後三綠也三深
但是他也順便有籌資
市場就不是很在意他的籌資
還是直接一架就漲停上去
廣達的籌資讓他吃蝶亭
這個事情應該要還他吧
對
所以我覺得接下來大家可能就會觀察到
他在接下來的這種所謂股價
針對這樣子的一個法術
或者數字來看的話
是不是有機會還他公道
OK
那麼廣達我們把它歸納在這個老AI
那我們來幫大家來看一下
現在的這老AI的一個族群
但實際上老AI的族群
我們叫做AI伺服器的一個組裝
其實AI伺服器組裝的領域
好像族群稍微擴大了
在去年我們大概是講說
老AI大概就是三雄鼎力
或者是四雄鼎力
但是今年在做AI伺服器相關的
這個個股來講變多了
包括像是技嘉 音樂達 神達
合塑 人寶 跟華塑等等
OK 好 那我們在這些所謂的
AI伺服器的一個組裝個股當中
特別觀察到
有一些的EPS已經公告出來了
例如說剛提到的
像是鴻海 廣達 還有像維穎等等
他們這些過去的
所謂的一個老AI的一個三雄
他們在今年上半年的EPS的
成長幅度好一點37%
這樣剛剛的廣達
然後鴻海大概只有25%左右
但是其實一些新出來的
包括像是這個音樂達
今年上半年的EPS的成長輔助
是61.47%
那麼甚至人寶還交出了
93.44%的一個好成績單
我想這個釋出必有因
這個空穴不來風
他們會有這樣子EPS大幅度的成長
一定跟他的基本沒有關
不過他們如果進來的話
會不會對於就所謂的
毛利率廝殺又要展開一波的競爭
因為這一波的話
鴻海昨天的毛利率
沒有就是第一點連搭
就會有一點點懷疑了
是的
對
我個人覺得這個訂單的分散
可能會發生
但是如果說從這個
各大些子批業者
他們還是在持續的在
結果資本支出的情況下
我覺得其實影響性應該不會太大
是
因為資本支出那麼大
總是大家要分得做
對
好
那我們來看一下
這麼多個股裡面
現在看一下剛所提到
就是比較屬於心境挑戰者的
例如說像2376的技嘉
很強耶
有沒有發現到
他們這些心境挑戰者
不管是技嘉或者是音樂達
他們的骨架表現 骨架形態
就跟廣達 跟紅外不太一樣
他們是這一波拉回
基本上連這個半年間都沒有碰到
就往上再做走高
對
OK
那這次拉回來的過程當中
其實可以觀察到
大陸持骨的部分
其實是沒有出現鬆動的
甚至還在持續往上
再做一個增溫
反倒式這個過程當中散戶
有一點點這個持股去出現這個減少
各式企業
再來這個是2355的音樂達
特別觀察到這波拉軌
大概就回程到基建附近
大陸持股的部分
也是持續往上就增加的
散戶持股是在那邊做減少的
在接下來他在整個
所謂的美國的休斯頓廠
他在擴充L10跟L11的高階系統組裝
所以對他們在接下來 Q3跟 Q4
他的營收的成長應該是可以值得期待
因為他們之前其實也是有表態過
技嘉好厲害 他快要回到這個高點區了
前波專員表態大概就是因為他們已經知道
他要去切入這個從 L6
這個切入到 L10跟 L11
那麼下一檔是這個大家可能比較沒有注意到的
就是合作
是 我跟委太剛也有消套論
因為他之前的獲利狀況真的不理想
本業不理想
對
當然是合受
我想他在最近這幾年
也一直在去尋找
這個轉型的一個方向
那麼終於被他找到了
被他找到了
公司預估今年
哇伺服器營收
會出現十倍數爆發
機器低啦 預計機器低
目標朝向千億元規模邁進
但重點是
他不是只有家庭L6
他就直接切到
這個所謂高單價
隨便你貴了整個
也就是L11的相關的業務
所以使得他在這一次的股價表現
跟剛剛的技嘉音樂達一樣
讓他回擊並沒有碰到半年線
在一個技嘉附近就亮說就做個打底
那麼今天網上出現這個開高走高
有創造漲停
對 盤中是有來到這個漲停板的價位
但是是漲停板沒有鎖住
那很正常啦
為什麼人家買在這邊等多久
等一個月 兩個月 兩個半月時間
終於拉上來可以做忽略了結
對不對
所以呢明天跟後天特別觀察到
有沒有辦法去針對今天的上影線做修正
如果上影線你能夠做修正的話
哇那個亮先駕行
亮先駕行
所以接下來的前波的高點
應該就是有機會去做個挑戰
好今天那也是想要挑戰一下
但是就有壓力了
是的 是的
好這個是在這個核輸的部分
好那剛才這個造化也問到
就是MSCI這個傳緊急公告
對 其空告
到底有多緊急
多緊急
也差一天而已不是
好 可是我們改成兩分鐘了耶
他還是一個影響啊
是啊 總是這是一個
處置期間大家的這個
交易的一個這個過程當中
可能會有點卡卡的
那所以因為這個消息呢
本來早上傳出來被納入的
那這些個股呢
早上開高之後就出現震盪
就出現震盪
但是這樣子的震盪
對我們投資人來講
到底是好事還是壞事
是不是能夠因為這樣子的一個緊急公告
讓股價能夠有機會跌低點
那我們進場去做一個切入
我們來看一下他的整個的一個基本面的表現
我們還是回到財報上
對
我們先來看一下剛剛的台藥
台藥還有剛剛另外一檔
是這個錦塑
錦塑 台藥跟錦塑
他們在今年累計的EPS的YOLY
台藥成長百分之162
很好 三位數
緊數也不差
163.43
兩檔差不多
對 所以在整個EPS成長的角度來看
基本上他們都大幅度成長
所以我覺得即便是有剛剛的
這種所謂的就是
暫緩納入的消息
我倒覺得其實也不至於說
股價會持續性的下跌
那麼如果說就像這個
宅板來看好了
本益比比較低的大概就整頂
整頂可以玩
他現在的這個本益比
大概就35倍
OK 這個是真頂
那自己PCB的部分來講
其實本一比有的高有的低
有的高有的低
那我們來挑一檔
就是拉回幅度比較深的
而且有滑的
有滑的
是這樣子是不是
好的
好 我們來看一下
來 這個是4958的真頂
很多生活朋友有關心他
因為他的價位
可能是目前四雄比較低的
法說會好像講的沒有很積極
所以似乎有點橫盤真理
過去其實真頂被大家所討論
就是因為他什麼都做
軟板也有硬板也有HDI板也有
然後反而最近IC載板前陣子
大家都在炒他的比重比較低
那麼後來他有在做擴產
擴產之後主要是針對這個高速的光模組的部分
去做個切入
所以大家對他的重新去做個評價
那麼短期內來講
這邊往上拉高的擴產當中
碰到是月線的反壓
那我想說真理完成之後
應該是有機會再往上去做重高
他之前也有傳出就是跟灰達之間
有一個HDI版的消息
公司還特地出來澄清
所以他最近是比較多雜音
是的
那麼再來是2313的滑通
滑通也是壓力有點小小大
他從305塊跌到150
對啊
這個是腰斬
所以這個地方
他回到就是半年線位置
那麼相較於這個增底
他這一波往上拉高
他是有突破月線的
所以能夠突破月線拉回
基本上我覺得他落底的機會
是相當相當的大
大陸持股的部分
在最近這一週有出現比較明顯的增加
這個是滑通
他來到他現增加的附近
看能不能讓參與現增的人賺多一點
再來還有一個族群
就財報數字不錯
然後前陣子股價的拉軌就是這個封測
封測 你看
我都配方他找說
累積一PS雙位數成長
然後也經營說歪歪大於零的
這些個股都相當相當的雞優
而且除了營收成長之外
基本上他們本一筆
除了這一個精彩
他本一筆是50多倍之外
基本上大家都在10倍 20倍左右的
這樣子的一個本一筆的一個區間
那我們一樣幫大家挑一個價格比較低的
是
本一筆比較低的
哎呀 也有一個滑
真好
你是臨時響的吧
好
來看一下2329的滑胎
是
美超為感應股
哦 好
不要忘記昨天美超為是大賬
沒錯 他這個大肌晚體
不知道 反正美菜威這個財報不錯
那麼華泰又是美超威
他在這個伺服器
主機板相關的這個所謂的供應商
供應合作夥伴
而且他還有這個切入到AI儲存
跟快閃機
一起的控制IC的
控制晶片的封裝
那這個波段拉回到這個地方
哇 總共60幾塊
跌到37塊
簡直基本上
拉回的幅度也堅定50%
那麼近期大陸知股已經給我開始
出現往上再做翻揚的情況
那反而散戶這邊開始去做一個退場
所以我覺得像這樣子的個股呢
因為跌深忙
再加上有一些這個題材的加持
所以接下來拉回可以給Tibet做留意
因為我們之前可能比較常講到
什麼日日光系格等等的
是 華泰我們好久沒關注了
算是一個低價位的選擇
沒錯 這邊非常謝謝維泰
謝謝大家
好 維泰剛剛一口氣
說實話 少了很多的資訊喔
但是我們統整消化一下
第一個就是所謂的AI一線軍
或者叫做伺服器代工廠商
他們從原本的三雄四雄
已經有擴散的效應
也許會有毛利率上的一些競爭
但是因為資本支出真的太大了
大家要分著做
而且可以發現最近就是機器低
有宣布要爆衝的
現在是盤面上的亮點
本一筆也都十分的合理
那至於像PCB
載板類的 通波機板類的
也後納入沒有關係
我們先用成長率來評估
他們都是很值得介入的族群
而比較叫做黃金右下角的封測
今天跟大家講的
有照額的話也有猥太的菜
那他的話目前是低價股的封測
這邊的話也是很值得大家在裡面做娃寶
那廣告回來骨魚要上場啦
那骨魚也要講 講的是照囉
現在有21檔市值破照的公司
股價有高有低
但是如果要買的話沒有錢
基金3000塊錢就可以做投資
而且搭配一些 AI 人工智慧
七月其實很多買基金的朋友
是買在低檔區
好 下跌的時候真的很害怕
覺得有便便宜 但是又不敢接
上漲了又覺得現在標的
剛剛講這麼多 我該怎麼辦
這邊就要來請教骨魚了
其實在下跌的時候
就是買東西的時候
沒有錯 但是每次我問你
你都不告訴我要不要買
沒有 我現在不用理你了
不用低檔自動投
對 一個月
據說啦
真正有在使用的朋友
是可以扣到10次喔
在七月喔
一路減便宜
現在反彈上來 開心到不行
當然現在的話
我們台股很厲害啦
光是照原市值的
就有21檔那麼多
其實呢
以前我只認識一個兆而已
是不是
他叫做兆華
真的嗎
可是呢
在這一波台股上來之後的話
我認識了21個兆
這不是我花心了
我還沒說你自己承認了
那我們來看一下目前市場的一個現況
目前台股因為我們的市值一直在往上走
所以 MSCI這一次的調整的話
那台股在各個指數上面幾乎
出現一個全面性的一個調整
那當然在裡面的這些很多的一個成分股
到目前為止他的表現非常的好
而且他上半年交出來的 EPS 的一個相關的數據
事實上也是非常的一個亮眼
所以我們來看一下
到目前為止台股除了有 MSCI 調升的一個題材
還有很多黨的一個趙源谷
逐漸出現在我們的市場當中
那這些的話都是很多的一個力多
對台股市場的一個加持
那亞克今天在創歷史新高
真的是很強
記憶體裡面的代表
那為什麼他會再創新高呢
因為他目前
他傳出說
他是現在的滴滴是長假的主導者
而且他爆出來的價格
比華邦店 甚至韓國的廠商
爆的更高
但是重點是
人家也買單了
既然人家買單 你又長假
你又是主導者
那當然我的股價創高
是這個理所當然的一個結局
那當然除了你說
你看到南亞客之外
還有幾檔公司
也是你在投資的路上
你會覺得很訝異的
怎麼會是他呢
對 不可思議啊 有一點
尤其是像川湖這間公司
其實以前我們在講川湖的時候
都會跟
比如說像新日新那些公司
放在一起看
一個在做導鬼
一個在看狡獵
對不對 狡獵還沒有發酵
導鬼的倒是先衝出去的
那我們來看一下
那為什麼他這一次
導鬼會衝出去呢
來我們先看
他最新的一個毛利率
騎士87%
預計今年的EPS
有機會會來到300塊
但是說實話
300塊錢也不是只有他
但他就已經變成萬元股了
但他明年的話
上看到420
所以也就是因為他的整個EPS
突破到300以上
才造成他今天的股價
一路往上去做一個飆升
那你覺得如果穿糊的話
那就錯了
我們的趙元股裡面
還有一檔很特殊的
富房氣
終於來了一檔
我們買得起的東西
對啊
南亞科都500了
川胡都1萬2萬3了
對 來檔這個100多塊
但是你買了起
但是你可能會看錯
他的獲利能力
那我們怎麼講呢
事實上的富邦金
他是一檔兆元股沒有錯
但是他的股價也默默的
來到了一個三位數
其實以前超過100
大家都嫌貴了
對 我剛才第一個印象
也是作為來一個100塊的話
被人還120吧
那128
以前我們看到富邦金
100說哇靠 怎麼那麼貴啊
對不對
可是現在你看前面看到500塊
1萬塊之後再來看100塊
好便宜喔
而且更重要的是喔
富邦金呢
他事實上他有一些字節的公告
你知道玄機藏在哪裡嗎
玄機就藏在金融業不能夠說出的真相
什麼東西啦
金融業呢
他表面上跟你講喔
這是他最新的公告
1到6月
我的ETS是6.67元
怎麼樣
感覺上不錯啊 行啊
還不錯喔 OK嘛
OK啦 OK啦
可是金農業因為我們的金管會
有很多的限制
所以導致他有一些獲利
說不出口
這邊要小心講
我們的主管機關
然後他會跟你講說
我如果今天是用這種方式
來做我的EPS統計的話
也就是說我有些處分利益
我可以放到我的EPS
來看的話
我實際上1到6月賺的錢
不是6.67
是13.17
什麼
也就是說上半年
我的
獲利的能力
已經超過一個股本了
那全年一看的話
怕是人啊
這不就兩個股本以上
妥妥在線了嗎
但是我必須問你了
你在評估他的EPS和本益比的時候
你要用哪個版本
我們一定保守的跟你用這個版本嘛
對不對
但是我如果真的要買的時候
我們會去評估他這個數字是不是真的
因為確實金融業
他在做處分利益的任列的時候
他是有一些限制的
因為之前他們做了一些選擇
所以導致現在的話
不能夠把獲利放到檯面上
所以這個數字也是真的
也是真的就當作一個輔助
因為他沒有辦法放到檯面上
就不好評估
對 但是他有強調一件事情
這個EPS
他是可以拿來當現金鼓勵發放的
所以他的發放能力會很強
所以呢有些人就會把說
副邦金其實以目前的狀況來講
他可能是有低估的
但是我們講到這邊
你有沒有覺得投資是一件很複雜的事情
長期覺得不然
我們節目怎麼能天天做呢
你看做產業
產業不一定看得準
看這些財報數據
有一些真相又隱藏在很後面的地方
你如果沒有對他很熟悉的話
事實上你是抓不到
這個產業發展的tempo的
所以最簡單的方式是什麼
就用基金就解決了嘛 對不對
可能大家很流行就是
覺得ETFETF變成市場現學
它掛在台股市場上交易
基金一天一個價
可是基金的門檻真的最低
就是幾千塊錢就可以開始的事情
對 而且基金它
以目前來講的話
它有非常多檔的一個基金
它目前整體的報酬的話
比家權指數還要來得高
以家權指數來講
近一年它的報酬率有83
可是有超過接近150檔的一個基金
他的報酬已經來到了111.7%
是遠遠高於家權指數的
而且我們來看一下
我們在這邊的話
幫你分成單比投資跟定期定額
我們來看這些主動式的基金
跟家權指數的一個比較
你有沒有發現
其實台灣的這些主動式的基金
他的表現還蠻好的
不論你是做單比的
還是你是做定期定額的
你都有機會可以拿到更好的一個績效表現
所以你如果今天想要拿到更多
那你應該要做一件事情
化被動為主動
去選擇這些比較基金的主動式基金
你就有機會在這
整個市場上升的這個趨勢裡面的話
得到更好的一個報酬
其實有段時間大家在網絡上有討論
不是很喜歡主動式的ETF嗎
對
後來就發現其實所謂的主動式基金
他們的報酬完全不輸
而且因為不用每天在那邊跟人家講
我買進賣出什麼
反而比較多了一層
我可以默默壓制滑水的功力
對 而且我們來看一下
在目前很熱門的這些基金
我都幫各位整理在這張表裡面了
從安聯山雄
好不好 到凱基 到統一 到原大 國泰
富蘭克林
我全部都幫你整理在這個地方
你只要看這張表
就可以看得出來
所以下面這行是我們的家全指數
家全指數
其實今年也很厲害
八成的家全指數
但是你是要跟其他這些優秀的基金
放在一起比的時候你就會發現
你如果滿足了八成
你就錯過了一百次
這個就是我們在投資的過程中
你必須要去面對這個問題
所以我們在做投資
常常是要去思考說
我到底要怎麼做
我才能夠有機會
在相同的趨勢裡面
拿到更好的一個績效表現
我們上次也有在討論
有的經理人很猛對不對
台股這波下沙
他是逆勢
沒有錯 一直加碼
我們就會害怕
對 然後就沒有人把我們的手
按在那邊 叫你加這樣子
這時候我就跟你說
系統的機制很重要
我們之前在介紹機庫通的時候
它有一個非常棒的功能
叫做低檔自動頭
那這個低檔自動頭的話
它的觸發條件是什麼
跟20日前的鏡子去做比較
如果達到跌幅
它就做加碼的一個動作
但是它有適用的類型
比如說像股票型跟平衡型
這是比較適合的
然後他有很多的選項
可以讓你來做一個選擇
所以我們就可以來看
假設你把這個機制放在
安聯的台灣科技
剛剛新一年的第一名
或是放在很熱門的統一黑馬上面
也是前段班
那我們就可以來看一下
純粹的定期定額
或是跌幅3%就加碼
跌幅5%就加碼
那他最後得到的一個機效表現
到底他會長成什麼樣子
你有沒有發現
你如果純粹定期定額
好像也還不錯
也不錯啊
所以這次就不要停扣啊
可是如果你有再去做一些加碼的話
你有機會可以拿到多20%以上的一個績效
你看
你如果今天投資的金額
如果夠多夠大的話
這20%
嚇死人
這也是一筆非常大的一個錢
在這邊
其實我覺得還有一個很重要的東西
就是次數
因為你有增加次數
所以你的本利盒
其實它的部位有效放檔
對 沒有錯
那這也是我們在做所謂低檔加碼的一個好處
你如果純粹的定期定額
你能夠扣到了次數
基本上是固定的
可是你有加了一個低檔自動扣的一個功能的話
一旦市場有回檔
它就幫你連續做加碼的一個動作
讓你有機會可以賺到更多的一個錢
所以我這邊幫各位舉一個例子
我以安聯台灣的科技基金為例
我們去看一下最近三年
假設我去設了一個低檔自動擴的功能
他到底在這三年裡面
哪些時間
他會開始幫你做加碼的一個動作
我們以近期的一個回測來看
7月這邊讓你擴好擴滿
那還有一次給你擴好擴滿是在什麼時候
在2025年年初的時候
也是給你擴好擴滿
關稅戰爆發的時候
對 所以你看
這兩個都是大家印象非常深刻
一個大幅度回檔的時間點
而我們透過回測的一個建議員發現
我如果有做設定
我在這個大家都不敢有敢加碼的時候
我透過系統的一個機制
連續幫我扣
讓我的整體的績效的話
可以進一步
再往上創造提升的一個效果
所以這個就是呢
低檔自動扣
他在系統上面
幫各位達成了一個非常良好的效果
因為同仁有設定嘛 對不對
3%可能扣3千 5%就扣5千
他扣到後來就
真的要補錢了
可以扣到10次以上
對 但是他現在很後悔
他應該把帳戶的錢補滿才對
沒有 他看起來蠻開心的
對 因為畢竟
那個有賺到這一波的一個帳值
所以我們來幫各位介紹一下
就是說我如果今天投資主動式的基金
有幾個原則是你一定要注意的
首先第一個
你一定要堅持
定期定額的去買基金
這個基本盤一定要堅持
對 然後不要隨便去做停扣的一個動作
然後第二個的話
你想要增加你的一個績效表現的話
像這種
幾乎通的低檔自動扣這種功能的話
你一定要做
一定要把它設定進去
因為它等同是自動幫你做
逢低
加碼的一個動作
那第三個的話
你可能要去思考一下
在我投資的過程中
我要不要去做一個停歷的策略
停歷的策略的話
取決於你是做長期還是做破端
你如果做長期投資的話
我只要有逢低加碼
讓我的部位一直往上裏加就好
反正你也沒打算要跑
可是你如果是做波段的
或者是說你喜歡
或者會要有一點點入袋的感覺
那就可以考慮說
比如說達到獲利目標的10到15%
我就賣掉一些
讓我的獲利真正進到口袋
然後你可以拿去花一下
這樣子的話才有激勵的效果
對不對
就嘴上說長期
心裡其實想先賺個波段
這是每個人都必然經歷過的一個過程
我覺得每個人都是在投資的過程中
然後慢慢地去摸索
會找到一個最適合你的一個道路
不過我們在這邊的話
要來幫各位再做一個提醒
因為事實上肌腹通
有點太過分了
又過分了是不是
每次來講肌腹通都覺得
已經夠過分了
還有更過分
因為他把他的通路又擴了更大
他其實這樣大家覺得很喜歡一點
就是他幾乎有很多的手續費
都幫大家省到最省了
對 他除了幫你省手續費之外
他現在還幫你把通路
不停不停的往外去擴大
那他現在又有新的一個動作了
你知道他最新的動作是什麼嗎
他這次跟郵局來做了一個合作
滲透到郵局去了
你要知道郵局的用戶是非常廣泛的
對不對
那他這一次的話
他就是可以讓你直接
在下載G-FOOT通的APP之後
你點選開戶
他可以讓你直接去選擇說
你跟你郵局的帳戶
直接來做綁定
是
那這樣子的話
你郵局的帳戶裡面的錢
就可以
透過幾乎通的APP
然後也可以來做基金相關的投資
而且在這一次比較特別的話
你如果完成
郵局的這個綁定動作的話
他還有送你一個購物金
真的多少錢
這是郵局那一邊的話
會提供一個購物金
來鼓勵你
透過郵局的帳號
還說一個長期投資的一個動作
那至於這個錢是多少的話
你可以自己去看一下相關的內容啦
好不好
好 這是一個釣魚線就對了
肌膚痛又把痛入擴增了
而且這次地藏自動擴有發揮
他都功效了
希望大家都開心喔
這邊謝謝谷玉
其實台股有所謂的
照元市值的產業
這個呢 也有利外資進來投資喔
因為以前都說台股是潛碟市場
規模都比較小
都中小企業
現在我們的結構慢慢的捉撞了
而資金也會來再進一步的益助
所以這裡面有很多好公司
有金融股
但是也有所謂的外援股
用基金幾千塊錢就可以投入
這個是第一個優勢
第二個優勢
如果在夏天的途中
您會害怕的話
低檔自動扣會幫您設定
你要3% 5% 10%都可以來扣
這一波就發揮很好的效果
那最重要的是
現在又多加了一個郵局通路
也可以開戶到郵局
來進行這個網路上面
買賣基金的相關手續
所以下載一下
肌膚通的APP
你們就能瞭解所有的事情了
那這邊還是要提醒
購買基金 購買ETF
都是有賺有賠 有風險的
身購前一定要詳閱 公開說明書
好 今天非常謝謝三外的編來到現場
採顧台到了4萬6千點
這波的反彈看似很急
不過有點算是
我覺得雨露均沾
大小股都有做反彈的情況
還瞎帶著非常好的財報力多
所以我們不妨在現階段
把重心回到好的基本面宣股上面
希望今天的理財單秀對你投資有幫助喔
明天再會了 掰掰